and i ended up vomiting on myself
is that true it's true but it was off to
the side someone handed me
this is the problem with this show is
that every time we make a good point
then one of us tells a story it makes
everybody who agrees with us go
oh no they're wrong and ray's trying to
make smart points
he's like well there's not a real matter
of federal reserve and i'm like shut up
you cut
because some of these people like you
they like you better than me in the
morgue
i've been alone with perfectly
attractive dead women before
there you go you just admitted that you
thought about what it would be like to
[ __ ] no
no no no no that's what he did
move on move on
[Music]
that's a big bubble of money
we we stop fisting you on the subway